nice to see you john and james
hello
james people are calling you a brilliant
madman because they are absolutely
loving this series and being the writer
for every episode is this everything you
wanted everything you envisioned
uh you know part of the fun of all of
this is everything
a lot of it is what i envisioned but a
lot of it is just discovering the magic
along the way and i have a great team of
people around me from the actors like
john daniel brooks and jennifer holland
all the way through our you know
production designers props makers and
costume designers and seeing you know
everything unfold in front of me as i
was doing it is part of the fun of
seeing the unexpected happen and of
seeing a special moment between two
characters whether it's a a humorous
moment or a dramatic moment that you
capture on film and find a way to work
into the scene that you didn't
necessarily think was going to be there
um you know some of it yes i imagined
and some of it was unexpected and that's
the best place to be in yeah that is the
best place and let's talk about the
magic because in the first episode we
kind of see chris and his tighty whities
dancing to like a tom cruise risky
business movement moment there uh john
is it harder to learn dance routines
compared to stunts
it's for me it's much harder because uh
the way i'm built uh i have certain
advantages to stunt work i get to do all
the powerful stuff
and dancing actually uh requires a sense
of rhythm and grace of which i have none
so it takes a lot of a lot of practice
for me and uh it was very
was very difficult
you're so much better you keep saying
you're such a better dancer than you
think you were so good
he's good so good that's right i know
yeah
they'll not remember the 60 takes you
mess up them and they'll only see the
one that they that was good enough to
make the show
you're you're really really good and
right off the top you also say f aquaman
everyone's talking about this tell me
you love aquaman
me personally yes
i've never had the luxury of an
interaction with aquaman
i
i uh so i would be
it would be tough for me to use the word
love to somebody that i've never met
so i can't i can't do the word love
injustice and say i love aquaman because
i've never met aquaman i'm sure
if in that circumstance we do meet maybe
share some commonalities or have a bond
maybe we could grow to love each other
i'm not sure i like him i love jason i
love jason momoa he's my friend he's a
good guy um but uh aquaman i mean he
might
he
listen peacemaker is jealous of every
single superhero there is whether it's
superman or batman or aquaman or green
arrow he is jealous of the guys that are
in the spotlight this is not the
superhero that is part of you know the
holy trinity he is a he's a superhero
who is way down on the list
to be up there and he's not and so he
spends a lot of time angry at what he
doesn't have yeah you know there's a
great storyline too with the father and
son i think it's a really important line
that everyone kind of needs to focus on
because he is a white supremacist and it
looks like chris also has a lot of daddy
issues what do you want people to get
out of that that plow that plot of it
you know i think that one of the things
with peacemaker is he has had a
really really crappy upbringing he has
had a tough time he has a terrible
father um who i don't think is has any
uh redeemable features
but chris
might and i think that's part of the
story of peacemaker is who is he as a
human being and one of the things that
we do is we get to see him interact with
daniel brooke's character leota adebayo
who is the polar opposite of him
politically
socially in every single way and yet
they form a love for each other it's not
a romantic love it's not a sexual love
but a love for each other and an
understanding of each other that is
unique and that friendship of people
reaching across from totally different
parts of culture to each other and
understanding each other as human beings
first and foremost i think is the heart
of the story and one of the things that
you know maybe we could all learn from a
little bit yeah john do you see yourself
a little bit in the peacemaker
uh of course i do um i think that's the
ability to act as well for me uh i i'm
is take experiences in my own life and
try to put them into character um you
know i wrestled under my own name but
the john cena character is the character
but there's a lot of me in the unseen
character i think in everything that i
do and every performance that i give is
my
my tools uh my skills to be able to take
my own personal experiences and try to
bring them to a character so uh
there is
things that i look for in myself that i
bring a peacemaker it's obviously uh
it's it's a whole lot different but uh
yes i i would draw on my own experiences
a lot for to craft peacemaker have you
seen yourself have you watched yourself
as a peacemaker
i've i've been fortunate enough to see
the first three episodes and i'm
extremely excited about the show and i
cannot wait we are just uh days away
from the world being able to see it yeah
canada being able to see it on crave and
i really hope everybody watches and
enjoys as much as i do yeah now one of
the great things about this series is
also the music the 80s rock and roll you
guys bring it what is your pump up song
what's that one song that you love to
listen to
james what's your pump up song
rolling in the deep by adele
really
yeah i mean there's i got a lot of them
but that's definitely one of them i love
that song you know i never i can never
listen to that song and not really be oh
not be dancing around that's okay it's
peacemaker promo it's scary
three f-bombs before they cut you off
yeah that is so true that is so true how
about you john
uh otis redding cigarettes and coffee
yeah yeah yeah
just that was strictly to just make
james go what
yeah
do you really want to taste it it's kind
of kind of been in my rotation lately
subliminally i don't know why
last night i started singing it in my
head i'm like
i've watched the opening sequence
probably
5 000 times and i'm still singing that
song
or my own pleasure
[Music]
[Laughter]
and james the fact that you love working
with john what makes him so special i
mean you got to work with him suicide
squad and doing the series i'm i'm
assuming season two is coming as well
well
maybe but i think that john john is just
a person of integrity you know and i
love surrounding myself with people of
integrity and i count myself as
enormously blessed um to have people
like john cena like chris pratt um in my
life for the people that are my collab
my great collaborators my partners in
telling stories um people who i really
like as human beings and who i really
like as artists who are totally
responsible in every way and not
everybody in hollywood is i won't work
with jerks and luckily i've got one of
the best guys in hollywood beside me um
a lot these days who is john and i'm
really really truly grateful for that as
i let him know all the time yeah
oh that's so sweet and john you know i
was on your instagram it looks like
you're a ted lasso fan is that right
no i i am i i love the show uh
and i think uh ted lasso is like the
opposite of peacemaker whereas
uh shows these these
bits of light where you want to root
form to be good yeah ted last was such
an ultimate good guy and you just you
want a root form to to catch a break and
they do a great job in that show i love
that and i have to tell you canadians
are really excited that you married a
canadian and uh i'm wondering if you had
a chance to come back to vancouver and
kind of visit and you know enjoy canada
a little bit well just let me say if uh
me being in in genuine deep love with
someone can inspire an entire nation i
think that's pretty powerful it is right
it is and she's an engineer like me so
i'm even more excited about that
you just never be the smartest person in
the room and i made sure of that
congratulations on the series it is
absolutely amazing james i think it's
probably some of the best work you've
done and i know people are really
excited about it and john you just
killed it and
it's very vulgar so i will make sure my
kids don't watch it but uh
congratulations to both of you
we'll come out with a pg version it'll
be six minutes long how would you do
that how can you do a pg version how can
you
james that's that's a challenge that's a
challenge right there we could do it we
could do it
take care everyone thank you thanks
everyone
you